so we've talked before about how
different social media networks
seem to appeal to particular demographic
groups and seem to be responsible for
the spread of different
types of disinformation and propaganda
one thing we know about facebook
specifically is that
in the 2016 election with regard to
hillary versus trump type propaganda and
fake news
and during 2020 with regard to the
pandemic
anti-vaxx propaganda etc facebook was a
really big
player and factor in the disinformation
and fake news and propaganda that was
read
believed and signal boosted by
older americans and indeed for some
period of time now donald trump has been
banned from twitter as well as facebook
and other platforms we will know
tomorrow whether donald trump will be
allowed back on facebook and i know that
it may seem
in some sense trivial but because we
know i mean listen
um trump followers fell
for the grift of donating to fight the
election results to the tune of what was
it 60-something 70-something million
dollars
in part because of the campaigns on
platforms like facebook and indeed the
facebook oversight board
has reportedly already decided but we'll
be announcing tomorrow morning
whether donald trump donald trump's
facebook account
will be reinstated there was this idea
previously
that at it because of what facebook said
when they banned trump
it was an indefinite suspension because
of the risk of allowing trump to
continue on the platform in terms of
violence and in terms of incitement
but that the language was about the
right now
in the aftermath of the january 6th uh
riots
in fact on january 7th but that it would
be revisited in the future and indeed
that revisitation has taken place place
and we are going to know
tomorrow the impact of this could be
huge
because donald trump has been relegated
to putting out
these written statements on presidential
former presidential letterhead
they read like tweets without a doubt
but he has not had that core audience to
share them you sort of need to go and
find them
uh or you need to be following certain
accounts that are signal boosting them
if donald trump is indeed back on
facebook this is going to reopen the
door
to all sorts of weaponized
disinformation and propaganda
it could play a role in the 2022
election given donald trump's
clear desire to be a sort of king maker
and to see the people he supports win in
2022. so this is not
a a trivial decision um it has
reportedly already been made
and you can be absolutely sure that if
donald trump is allowed back on facebook
it's also going to put some pressure
on other social media platforms to allow
donald trump back on because the
listen i i'm the first to admit it's
unusual that a former president is
banned from all of these platforms i
don't think it's a free speech issue
every single one of these platforms as
i've talked about before has every legal
right
to say violations of our terms of
service are going to be met with
consequences regardless of whether it's
a former president or not
but it's so trump is so unusual
in how he used these platforms to spread
this disinformation
and we now find ourselves in the really
weird situation where
the the former president is not able to
use these platforms so the pressure if
facebook says trump's coming back on
for twitter and youtube and whoever else
to say we're also letting trump back on
that the danger has passed so to speak
uh is going to be significant so we'll
see what that decision is that's made
tomorrow
we'll of course uh very quickly i think
see what
use donald trump plans to make of these
platforms and although in the aftermath
of these bans
donald trump has said he's happy not
being on them things are better or he's
you know whatever i think it's
abundantly clear that
if given the opportunity he will
immediately start making use of those
platforms
don't forget that one of the best ways
to support the david pakman show is by
supporting our sponsors
and today one of those sponsors is
sheath
underwear sheath underwear makes boxer
briefs
specifically designed to prevent the
sticking
the rubbing the chafing that many of us
know all too well with traditional boxer
briefs
sheath boxer briefs have multiple
ergonomic
compartments in the front to prevent
skin on skin contact
keeping everything separate cool dry
and comfortable extra helpful now that
the weather is warming up
no more sweatiness no more chafing
no more readjusting sheath underwear is
giving the david pakman show audience 20
off when you go to sheath underwear dot
com slash pacman
use the promo code pacman give sheath
underwear a try
i've had a great experience with it i
think you will too
you can find the link right underneath
this video and don't forget to use
promo code pacman for twenty percent off